remember the anguish of fishing
communities over britain's brexit trade
deal with the eu the new rules and red
tape the warnings of catches rotting on
the key side of businesses going past
a year on and here in the south devon
port of brixum things are looking up
at its famous fish market they're having
an especially busy week the innovation
of online bidding means buyers from all
over europe are just a mouse click away
that there 254 that's delicatessence
he's from belgium
sales are worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars a day
the new export paperwork's a hassle but
they've got used to it so that orders
are received by the following morning
brexit what brexit i would say the
fishermen are no better off but what i
would say is an auction the main auction
company in england we are probably
better off because the fishermen used to
take their fish across the water
themselves and sell it on the european
market but now because there's so much
red tape we go up and post now we pick
that fish up and we we do all that
administration for them high fees to
access this booming cooperative means
smaller operators are much more at the
mercy of fluctuating prices so they too
have had to adapt with some expanding
into direct sales because everyone's
locked in and if they ring up we deliver
or we'll send it out so
i think probably it's more to do with
covid
i don't think it's to do with brexit
we're just
every week is different
you know we're we're adapting to
to each week as we go it's like in the
fish shop you know the prices go up and
down you adapt to it you've got to
adapt to survive
so it's a nuanced picture yes fish
exports are strong and yes changing
habits after lockdown have created a new
appetite for fish at home but some are
doing better than others
it's a picture of an industry learning
to make the best of a complicated trade
deal rather than reaping any rich
rewards
chef and restauranteur mitch tonks has
been putting british fish on diners
plates for years he's now also doing a
roaring trade online
brexit had the fishing fleet you know
firmly in uh
in the picture the whole time which was
which was good and of course i think the
british public are waking up to the fact
how great our seafood is and i think
whichever whichever you believe whether
you want to be in or out there is a
certain resolve and unity i think
amongst british people and we see our
british fishermen we want to support it
we want to eat our fish i think that's
that's been a huge plus and it's a
pretty huge turnaround for an industry
that just a year ago was predicting its
own demise
jonah hull al jazeera brixem